انا بحب
المص بحبها يا قصيله
كحت بس مره كنت مستعجل واليوم كان طويل
فقلت لا انا هركب كريم ج الراجل اللذي ده
وطف جدا معايا ودلعني
وعجل عقلت ماشي مش مشكله خدت اللبانه وان
قاعد ومستر والشن بي اسوسي شغاله والح
حلوه ف سمحلي في التفكير وانا سرحان
اكتشفت ان البان دي كانت تقريبا اول حاجه
اكلها اول من اول يوم بقي 14 ساعه ما
حطيتش حاجه في بقي غير اللبان بس الفكره
انا ما كنتش مداق بالعكس انا كنت فرحان
كنت فخور فخور ان انا قدرت بعقلي اتغلب
على قدرات جسمي ماخليش الجوع يقف عقبه في
طريقي ماين اوفر
مات اكتشفت ان انا اصلا ما بحبش الاكل ع
دي حاجه ممكن تبان غريبه بالنسبه لكم بس
انا شخصيا انا اللي بحس اللي بفكر اللي
بشوف اللي بفرح اللي بزعل مش بستفيد حاجه
لما اكل او اشرب او انام او اخش الحمام او
اي حاجه محتاجات الجسمانيه دي ان انا اقعد
مستلقي على السرير ثمان ساعات فاقد الوعي
تضيع وقت لكن بقت فعلا هو جسمي الوعاء
الهش اللي بيحتويني جسمي ضعيف وبيكبر لي
ان انا البي جاته لم ان هو يتكرم ويفضل
يحتويني يحتوي فكري يحتوي وعي يحتويني
انا ثانيه واحده يعني بتقول ان انت وجسمك
مش حاجه كواحده طب لو انا مش جسمي انا ب
مين
فلنفترض ان انا اتولدت بع خ مثلا ناقص
فيباع هل ده بيدم ل انسانيتي في حاجه انا
كده ماعدتش بني ادم ماعدتش بعرف افكر او
احس او اشوف او اسمع او افرح او زعل هل
انا كده ده بيقلل من كلون انسان في اي
حاجه تالي لا طب لو انا كنت مثلا في
السعوديه وسرقت وقطعوا ايدي هل ده بيخليني
انسان ناقص هل انا ما قتش بعرف افكر ما
قتش بعرف افرح ماش بعرف ازعل ماش بعرف احس
برض لا طب يعني مثلا بتت ناقص ايد اتنين
ناقص ايدي اين ورجلي ناقص جوارح كلها برض
لا طب اقدر اكمل كده لحد امتى ايه الحاجه
اللي لو شلتها مابقاش انا ايه الحاجه اللي
لو شلتها تخليني بني ادم ناقص انا ابقى
مين اجابه بديهيه ممكن تخطر على بالنا هو
العقل دماغي محتا كل افكاري وشخصيتي واتي
ده بيكوني انا طب هنا السؤال لو احنا
افترضنا ان ده فعلا انا لو انا شلت دماغي
من بره جسمي خالص احنا اتفقنا ان احنا مش
محتاجينه وحطيته جوص الكمبيوتر الكمبيوتر
ده عليه سيموليشن او محاكاه برنامج بيقلل
الواقع بالضبط بحيث ان هو مثلا لو الدماغ
ده بعتت اشاره ان هو يحرك ايده فالكمبيوتر
بيحرك الايد اللي جوه السميشن وفي نفس
الوقت بيبعت اشارات للدماغ كانها جايه من
عينيه ومن ودانه فهو بيشوف وبيسمع
فبالتالي العالم ده هيبقى عايش كانه
بالضبط في العالم الحقي بتاعنا ه بيشوف
وبيفكر وبيحس و ما عندوش اي فكره انف
سمليشن بالنسبه له هو في العالم الحقيقي
بالضبط مش حاسس باي فرقه فهل ده
يبقى
انا
حت اصلا محتاج نفسها في
حاجه خليني
احكيلكم في اليونان القديمه كان
اس كان الحاكم الاسطوري لمدينه في اليونان
القديم الحاكم ده استطاع ان هو يتغلب على
وحش اسطوري بجسم انسان
ور
طبعا ولا حاجه ولا
يس المهم بعد معركته الملحميه في كرييت
وتغلب على الوحش ده رجع تاني لاتينا على
متن السفينه دي اللي نقبت باسمه ده
شيبس ال القدماء قدروا جدا هذه المعركه
العظيمه فقرروا ان هم يحلوا ذكراها كل سنه
بانهم ياخدوا نفس السفينه يروحوا بيه
منكري حدنا بنفس السفينه كل
سنه مشكله بدات تظهر ان مع مرور الزمن
ممكن مثلا بدات خشبه تقع في البحر مسمار
يتفك حته تبوز فقالوا مش مشكله بدلوها
وحطوا حته تانيه مكانها وبرضو لسه اسمها
وبرضو لسه كل سنه بيحتفلوا بها وياخدوها
من ك
لحد بعد كذا سنه بدات برض حتت تانيه تقع
ويبدلها بحتت جديده ولسه برض
اسمها والناس تقول راحت جفيش اي مشكله بعد
ال سنه
من
ورحله
السفين اي قط موجو
منشبه
حؤ ولا
لا سؤال محير فديك شويه كده تفكروا
فيه مين شايف ان دي
[موسيقى]
مشع اوكي عدد مش قل يكس يه احب ابشركم
بشار كويسه قوي انت
مش ان انت ما تفرقش اي حاجه على
السفينه انت جسمك مكون من ملايين الخلا
ال خلايا دي كل شويه قاعده بتموت ويتم
استبدادها بخلايا تانيه بمعدل سريع جدا
لدرجه انها من ساعه وبدات كلامي كل واحد
فينا بدل حوالي 200 مليون
خليه فالمعدل ده انا ممكن دلوقتي ما يبقاش
في ولا ذره في جسمي كانت موجوده فيا وانا
لسه
موجود بس مع ذلك انا لسه نفس الشخص لسه
نفس البني ادم ما حصليش حاجه فبالتالي ده
ممكن يفهمنا لا هي فعلا تشكي سس بس اللي
بيديني انا هويه مش خلايا جسمي مش حاجه
ماديه مش حاجه ملموسه حاجه اكبر من مجرد
خلايا جسمي او حتى عقلي حاجه ماقدرش
امسكها يا ترى ايه الحاجه دي في ناس
اقترحت انها ممكن تبقى
ذكريات فكره ممكن تبان غريبه لحد ما
احكيكم قصه معينه فنفترق ان في واحد عمل
الجريمه عندي كل الادله اللي بتثبت ان هو
فعلا العمل للجريمه دي صوت وصوره وبصمته
على سلاح الجريمه وكل الادله وتشير ان هو
ده فعلا اللي عمل
الجريمه فبيس راح يجد علىيه بيجري ورا
بالعربيه الراجل عمل حادثه اتقلب خبط راسه
جالله فيقان ذاك مع ذلك برض بيصح قبط عليه
وجابه يستجوبه وبدا يساله عن الجريمه بس
مهما حاولوا يسالوه برض الراجل مش عارف اي
حاجه مش عرف يجاوبها بيقسم بالله ان هو
بريء ولو حطيناه على جها شس الكذب برض
هيطلع ان هو سادر لان هو فعلا سادر هو
بالنسبه له هو كان نايم فجاه صحي لقى
البيز بيبض يستجوبه عن جريمه هو عمره ما
سمع حاجه عنها ماعرفش اي حاجه عن
تفاصيلها فالسؤال
هنا هل ده يبقى الشخص اللي عمل الجريمه
ولا لا هل مفروض تجينه ولا
لا ترى مين شاف كده مش مفروده زجن يرفع
ايده
بر تقريبا اكتر من نص شايفين انها مش
مفروده زجنا فدايما لنا حاجه مهمه جدا ان
على الرغم من ان الشخص اللي عامل الجريمه
والشخص اللي واقف قدامي ده عنده نفس الجسم
وعنده حتى نفس العقل بس الحاجه الوحيده
اللي اتغيرت هي ذكرياته وده كان كفيل ان
هو يخليه بني ادم تاني تماما تحد الناس
عشان تثبت اكتر قد ايه الذكريات ممكن
بتشكل جزء مهم قوي من اللي احنا عايشين
فيه اقترحت تجربه لطيفه كده نفكر
فيها تخيلوا ان الكون ده كله بكل ما فيه
اتخلق من خمس دقائق بس من خمس دقائق كل
ذره في الكون كل النجوم والكواكب والاقمار
والارض اللي احنا قاعدين فيها والمصرح
اللي انا واقف فيه وانا وانتم وال المكتبه
اللي جنبنا بكل الكتب اللي فيها اللي
بتحكي عن قصص زمان بالحفريات اللي في
الارض اللي بتدينا ايحاء ان كان في حياه
من ملايين السنين كل ده اتخلق من خمس دقاق
بس وخلق مها برضو ذكرياتنا اتخل معها
ذكرياتي وانا بقي اربع شهور بحضر دي اتخل
معها كل اللي احنا فاكرينه عن العالم
والماضي من خمس ز بس عالم زي ده لو جينا
نتخيله مش فارق اي حاجه عن الواقع هبقى
فعلا حسين كان الحقيقي لان كل اللي حصل
موجود هنا حد ممكن يقوللي لا بس مثلا انا
وانا صغير عندي سبع سنين كان بيوديني
الجامع وان مش لسه عندي الذكريات دي من
خمس دقاق انا عندي ذكريات انا عندي 10
سنين مثلا بس برض انت مش متاكد من ده كل
اللي عندك هو ذكريات لنفسك وانت عندك ع
سنين وانت عندك ذكريات لنفسك وانت عندك سب
سنين كل ده مكن خ د بس وهتبقى حاسس كانك
بقك 17 سنه
عاش ف انا قد ايه الذكريات دي تشكل فعلا
العال اللي احنا عايشين فيه وده بيطرح
اسئله اخطر واخضر يعني مثلا لو انا جبت كل
ذكرياتي وكل تجارب حياتي وحطيتها على
الكمبيوتر برض الكمبيوتر متوصل بنفس
السميشن عنها قبل كده بس المره دي م عنديش
دماغ م عنديش جسم ما عنديش اي حاجه بس برض
الكمبيوتر ده هيبقى عنده نفسه ذكرياتي
وعنده نفسه ذك ب حياتي عن نفس شخصيتي لو
جه كلمناه هكلمكم كان انا بكلمكم بالضبط
هي حكي لكم برض عن وانا عندي سبع سنين
وبايه ويديني الجامع هيبقى كاني انا
بالظبط اللي
بتكلم ف هل ده يب انا ولا لا انتم عايزين
تقولوا لا وانا شخصيا برضو عايز اقول لا
بس الفكره ما حدش عارف يقول لا ليه انا كل
اللي اعرفه ان انا شخصيا واعي انا بعرف
افكر بعرف اشوف بعرف اسمع بعرف افرح بعرف
ازعل انا افكر اذا انا
اكون بس انا مع عنديش دل ان بقيه الناس دي
دي عندي وعي هم بيقولوا ان هم واعيين وانا
بصدقهم فلو الكمبيوتر ده قالي ان هو واعي
صدقوا
ولا عشان بس الناس الانيه شبهنا فاحنا
بنستقبل بصدقهم ان هم فعلا معيين بس احنا
عارفين في كنات تانيه ممكن تبقى واعيه في
جوريلا اسمها كوكو بتتعلم لغه الاشاره
وبتعرف تتواصل مع البني قدمين وحتى لما
القطه بتاعتها ماتت عبرت عن اسها وحزنها
وكل يوم عن يوم مبداك الحوام بتبهرنا بقد
ايه هي اشبه بنا ما بكوننا
نتصور فحنا عارفين في حاجات تانيه ممكن
تبقى واعيه ليه ما يبقاش ده برض
واعي هو بالظبط هيبقى بيفكر كاني انا هنا
بالضبط مش هيحس باي فرق عن الحياه
الواقعيه فلو كده مش ممكن انا اصلا اكون
في سمليشن برض ايه رايكم ان اغلب الظن
احنا فعلا عايشين في
سمشن ايه المص اللي هو عمل سبيس اكس
وتيسلا وباي بال عنده حجه ممنوعه جدا ليه
احنا فعلا عايشين في سميش دلوقتي ح فنفت
احنا دلوقتي في العالم الحقيقي مع تقدم
التكنولوجيا بتاعنا قدرنا نوصل خصوصا بقى
الكوانتم كبيوت بقى عندنا كمبيوتر قوي
كفايه لدرجه ان هو يعمل سمليشن
للكون كله كل ذره في الكون كل ذره في
النجوم والكواكب والاقمار والارض وفيا
وفيكم في المسرح و كل ذره في الكون معمول
لها
سش فبالتالي الكون ده برضو هيبقى في ناس
عايشه زينا وبتتكلم وبتفاعل وبتفكر وبتحس
وبالنسبه لهم كانهم عايشين في العالم
الحقيقي بالضبط مش حاسين باي فرق عننا لان
كل ظره في جسمهم زي ما تكون في الحقيقه
بالظبط طب مش هم لو زقنا قوي كده مش عندهم
برض تكنولوجيا مش هم برض عندهم كمبيوترات
مش ممكن مع تقدم الزمن بتاع بيفكروا برض
يعملوا سمليشن
لنفسهم والسيمي شن برض التانيه دي برضو
عندهم كمبيوترات تكنولوجيا وبرضو عايزين
يعملوا سميشن لنفسهم فمن العالم واحد
حقيقي قدرت اطلع ب 10 20 100 الف مليارات
الاكوام اللي مش حقيقيه اللي في سمليشن
فانا دلوقتي لو لسه موجود حالي مش عارف
انا فين احتماليه اكبر بكتير ان انا كون
اتولدت في واحد من المليارات السميشن بدل
ما كون اتولدت في الواحد الوحيد
الحقيقي فحنا فعلا عاشين
فيش النقطه دي هتوصل هتحصل لا محاله
سببين اول سبب هو ان البشر منذ بدايه
التاريخ دايما عندهم دافع ان هم يطوروا من
نفسهم يشوفوا ايه الباون اللي قدامهم
ويعدو دايما معدل تزايد العلم بتاعنا
بيزيد بمعدل متزايد فطول ما احنا عندنا
الفعه دي طول ما احنا نفضل نطور في التكن
بتاعتنا احنا فعلا هقى
عندنا السبب التاني والاخطر هو احنا
عايشين في عالم محكوم بقوانين فيزيا ثابته
ومتوقعه
ماشين اشر حاجه في المعادلات
الرياضيه
قصدي ايه لما بقول قوانين فيزياء ثابته
يعني مثلا انا لو جبت كور ورميتها وعدت
التجربه دي 500 مره لو كل مره سبت الكوره
من نفس المكان بنفس الارتفاع كل مره هترد
بنفس السرعه في نفس الاتجاه بنفس كل حاجه
لان القانون اللي بيحكم الحركه دي
الجاذبيه سبت ما
بتتغيرش فبالتالي انا مهما غيرت لو انا
ثبتت الانبوت دايما الاوتو هيبقى ثابت لان
البروس من جوه ما
بتتغيرش طب ثانيه واحده هو مش انا برض
عايش في الكون
ده انا القوانين اللي بتحكمني نفس
القوانين بتحكم الكوره دي والذرات اللي في
جسمي تفيش اي حاجه عن الذرات اللي في
الكوره دي هل ده معناه ان انا لو عدت
تجربه الكون ده كله 500 مره الكون بدا
بنفس الطريقه كنت انا كل مره هتولد لنفس
الاب والام بنفس الظروف واخد نفس قرارات
حياتي كل مره كنت بقى واقف هنا
اكلمكم هل ده معناه ان احنا ما عندناش
اراده
حره ثانيه واحده ثانيه واحده قبل الناس
تتجنن فاكرين كل ده بدا من ايه بدا من
سؤال واحد بسيط انا مين سؤال بان سهل
وبيسال منذ بدايه التاريخ ما كانش قبل
التاريخ كمان لحد دوقتي مش لاقين اجابه دي
مش مشكله لان الهدف من السؤال مش ان انا
اجاوب بس ان انا الاقي اسئله اكتر سؤال
يجيب سؤال يجيب سؤال يجيب سؤال لان احنا
مهما سالنا في اسئله عمري ما هعرف الا
مهما تقدمنا في التكنولوجيا وفي العلم
احنا محدودين على الاقل انسانيتنا محدودين
بان انا كل حاجه بشوفها بحسها بفكر فيها
بسمعها فهي محصوره هنا محصوره في دماغي
ماقدرش اطلع بره دماغي وابص فوق على
العالم الحقيقي لان مافيش عالم حقيقي
مافيش حقيقه مجرده كل حاجه هنا كل حاجه
تهيؤات جوه
دماغي فانا ممكن معرفش اجاوب بس كل اللي
اقدر اعمله هو ان انا اسال وفي النهايه
ههم سؤال دلوقتي هو الغدا امت
شكرا
الله